you are
terrified afraid concerned about the
dragon of something we can call
communism Marxism
by terrified of it well okay be a tyrant
your theories had two components yeah
I'm not paralyzed at a dragon yeah I'm
not paralyzed and I don't want to be a
tyrant the Taran part I think is missing
with you
um so you are very concerned the
intensity of your feeling
uh does not give much space actually at
least in your public persona for sitting
quietly with the dragon and sipping in a
couple of beers and thinking about this
thing
the intensity of your anger
concern about certain things you're
seeing in society is that going to drive
you off the path that ultimately takes
us to a better world that's a good
question I mean I don't I'm trying to
get that right so we've kind of come to
a cultural conclusion about the Nazis
do you get to be angry about the Nazis
seems the answer to that is yes
well actually let me push back here
um I also don't trust people who are
angry about the Nazis because I mean the
actual Nazis well I I there's a lot as
you know there's a lot of people in the
world
um that uh use actual Nazis to mean a
lot I think I know one of them is very
important to me for example
he did not say I think or magical super
Nazi as it turns out I think they
actually sort of Steel Man all their
perspectives they I think a lot of
people that call you a Nazi mean it
there's an important thing there though
because I I went to the front in Ukraine
yeah and a lot of the people
uh that lost their home or their kind of
uh that got to interact a lot with the
Russian soldiers Ukrainian people that
interact with the Russian soldiers
uh they reported that the Russian
soldiers really believed their saving
the the people
of Ukraine in these local Villages from
the Nazis I understand yeah so to them
it's not just that the Ukraine
government has or Ukraine has some Nazis
it's like it has been the idea is that
the Nazis have taken over Ukraine and we
need to free them this is the belief so
this again Nazi is still a dragon that
lives yeah and it's used by people
because it's safe to sit next to that
dragon and spread any kind of ideology
you want so I just want to kind of say
that we
um have agreed on the uh on the on the
on the uh on this particular Dragon but
I still don't trust anybody who uses
that yeah but we have issues with
boundaries right no no it's so this is a
very complicated problem right so Renee
Gerard believed that
it was of human proclivity to demonize
the scapegoat and then drive it out of
the village and yeah I've thought about
that a lot we need a place to put Satan
like seriously this is a serious issue
should you be inside the village or
outside well maybe he should be inside
you
right that's that's the fundamental
essence of the Christian doctrine it's
like
Satan is best fought on the battleground
of your soul
and that's
that's right
it's right